the crucial turning point in the kyle
rittenhouse's murder trial in wisconsin
testimony ended yesterday when the
defense rested its case the 18-year-old
claims he was defending himself when he
shot three men killing two of them
during a protest after a police shooting
in kenosha prosecutors allege he went
there with a rifle to cause trouble
nancy chin is outside the courthouse in
kenosha nancy good morning
nate good morning to you after nearly
eight days of hearing from witnesses
including at times emotional testimony
jurors will soon get the case and decide
the fate of kyle rittenhouse
what was going through your mind
at this particular moment that i was
going to die a week of often times
emotional testimony including the
possibly pivotal moment when kyle
rittenhouse himself took the stand
ended with the defense portraying a
chaotic and fast moving chain of events
on that summer night in kenosha as one
of their experts said the shootings that
ultimately killed two and seriously
wounded another man unfolded in mere
minutes what is the total amount of time
of this event
two minutes and 55 seconds approximately
it's
calculated out there's a bunch of
variables in there the jury also seeing
new video shot by a blogger who backed
britton house's claims he had reason to
fear for his life drew hernandez
testified that joseph rosenbaum who
written out shot and killed posed a
threat he led the charge
into the gas station he was getting
physically aggressive the prosecution
worked to paint hernandez's bias
referencing social media comments he had
made in the past have you ever posted
anything on social media
yes in support of kyle rittenhouse
one could argue yes there was also
continued tension between prosecutor
thomas binger and judge bruce schroeder
get brazen with me after the two
repeatedly clashed wednesday this time
over what video could be analyzed
yesterday
i was
the target of your ire
for disregarding your orders today the
defense is disregarding your order the
judge has yet to rule on the defense's
motion for a mistrial with prejudice
which means that this trial would be
over and written house could not be
charged again in the meantime as we do
near a verdict kenosha police say
they're getting ready tony
nancy thank you very much